we're told that each square below
represents one whole so this square is a
whole this is another hole so together
that's two
and then we have something less than a
whole and they say what decimal is
represented by the shaded area so it's
going to be two and then something so
it's going to be two point something and
let's think about what we have over here
this is one whole two holes and then
over here we've taken a hole and we've
divided it into one two three four five
six
seven 8 9 10 equal sections so we've
divided it into tenths each of these
bars is equal to a tenth and we have
seven of them shaded in one two three
four five
six seven
so this right over here is seven tenths
so this is going to be one two and seven
tenths
so
if we wanted to write it as a mixed
number we'd write it as two and seven
tenths but they say what decimal is
represented by the shaded area so
instead of writing two and seven tenths
we could write 2.7
because the space immediately to the
right of the decimal points that's the
tenths place so we have two ones two
holes right over here and then we have
seven tenths this is the tenths place
and we could check our answer we got it
right let's do another one of these
so same thing what decimal is
represented by the shaded area so we
have three wholes and then this
whole is divided into tenths now it's
divided into these vertical bars we have
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 vertical bars
they're equal so they're divided into
tenths and we've shaded in five of them
so this one over here is five tenths so
it is three wholes and five tenths
so it's going to be three wholes
and in the tenths place we would put
five three point five three wholes and
five
tenths we can check our answer got it
right let's do a few more of these
what decimal is being represented by the
shaded area
so over here let's see i have i have a
hundred squares you see i have 10 i have
10 columns and each of them have 10
squares in it so 10 times 10 is 100. so
i have 100 squares here equal squares so
i've divided it into hundredths and i've
shaded in 1 2 3 4 five six seven eight
nine of the hundredths hundredths so how
do i represent that
so zero that's the ones place that's the
tenths tenths place and now i'm in the
hundredths place and so this we have
nine of the hundredths shaded in so this
right over here would be nine hundredths
which is exactly what we have there
all right let's do
let's do one more of these
all right well it's the same thing
we have two of the hundredths filled in
so i'll write zero point if i did that
that would be two tenths that's not what
we have filled in we have two hundredths
hundredths filled in so this is zero
point zero two and we're done